this math puzzle is causing a stir on
the internet
cheryl's birthday is one of ten possible
dates
cheryl does not tell her birth date to
anyone
but she does tell the month of her
birthday to albert
and the day of her birthday to bernard
albert says out loud i don't know
cheryl's birthday but i know that
bernard doesn't know it either
upon hearing this bernard says
i didn't know her birthday at first but
now i do know
albert replies
now i also know cheryl's birthday
when is cheryl's birthday
it seems impossible but you can figure
it out based on the logic of what each
person said
hi this is presh talwalkar in this video
i'm going to give the solution to
cheryl's birthday problem
let's take a look at the information
we're going to consider the sentences
one at a time
when albert says he doesn't know
cheryl's birthday that's obvious
but what's important is he says he knows
for sure that bernard does not know the
birthday either
how could he know that how is this
possible
well imagine bernard was told the date
of 19. in that case bernard would know
it would have to be may 19th that's the
only date with the 19.
if bernard was told
the date of 18
he would also know that the birthday has
to be june 18th that's the only date
with an 18.
so when albert says he knows that
bernard cannot know the birthday
he must have been told the months of
july or august so it couldn't possibly
be may or june
so we can eliminate five of the dates
and be left with only five of the dates
bernard figures this out and upon
eliminating five of the dates he says
all right i didn't know cheryl's
birthday at first
but now from these five dates i can
figure it out
so this can eliminate a few more dates
if bernard was told 14th it would still
be ambiguous whether the month was july
or august so bernard was not told 14th
there are now only three possible dates
that cheryl's birthday could be
albert now says finally he says now i
know cheryl's birthday
so obviously he couldn't have been told
it was august because there are two
dates for august so we can eliminate
that he was told august he must have
been told july
so that's cheryl's birthday it's july
16th
i know it's complicated to follow
through the logic but it's
mathematically sound
if you need to check it out you can read
my blog post it sometimes is easier in
text
but the birthday is july 16th and that's
the only logically consistent date
i hope you like this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and math puzzles
you can get my books there's a link in
the video description you can follow me
on my blog mind your decisions which you
can catch on facebook and google plus
you can also follow me at preshtalwalker
on twitter instagram tumblr and
pinterest and you can support me on
patreon